Let's talk a little bit about the stock market.
We have an impeached president here in the
United States.
One of the predictions that Donald Trump made
many times in the lead up to his impeachment
was the markets will crash if you impeach
me.
Now it turns out it didn't happen.
Markets have actually been fine since Donald
Trump was impeached last Wednesday by the
house of representatives.
A reminder, here's Donald Trump in September
when he quote, if they actually did this,
the markets would crash.
Do you think it was luck that got us to the
best stock market and economy in our history?
It wasn't.
Now there's a few things that I think are
important to talk about here.
First of all, the way the market is believed
to work supposedly works according to market
evangelists is that the market reflects all
known information at any point in time.
So for example, when Donald Trump was impeached
last Wednesday, it makes sense that stocks
didn't move hugely on that news because it
was known that Donald Trump would be impeached
the previous week when it became clear that
the house judiciary would be voting to impeach.
Knowing that Democrats control the house,
we actually learned well in advance of the
actual vote in the house that there would
be an impeachment of the president.
Case in point, when Nancy Pelosi first announced
the impeachment inquiry on September 24th
the Dow actually did drop a few hundred points,
but then those losses were recovered and the
stock market has actually occasionally hit
new highs since that day and we can debate
whether that matters, what that says about
the economy, who that affects.
That doesn't change any of the sort of deeper
underlying economic questions around looking
at the stock market.
But increasingly there is this idea that actually
impeachment of a president of the United States
when it is Trump specifically, it wouldn't
affect the economy that much.
Now, of course, if the act of being impeached
throws Donald Trump into an erratic panic,
he could do something nutty that would affect
the economy.
He could make a rational decisions about trade
policy.
For example, he could bomb a country, he could
start a military conflict or he's liable to
do a lot of different things that would move
the markets as soon as it is known that that
is something Trump is going to do.
But in terms of Trump's impeachment itself
and the hypothetical removal from the Senate,
even though of course it appears that he is
going to be acquitted when that Senate trial
ultimately happens, we have a known tax system,
for example, we have known regulatory infrastructure
trumps conviction or acquittal in the Senate,
uh, is not going to change those things in
any direct way.
It's actually possible that Trump's conviction
on impeachment, which would remove him, would
maybe better relations with other countries,
even if it's totally wacky, ideological right-wing
Christian Mike Pence who were to replace Donald
Trump.
It's hard to imagine a more cartoonish laughingstock
than Donald Trump when it comes to international
relations.
So, uh, believe me, I don't want Mike Pence
to be president.
Even that I think could arguably be an improvement
in some sense.
What the stock market doesn't like is a surprise.
And so far Donald Trump's impeachment has
progressed in pretty predictable steps.
Conviction is now a question Mark, but again,
presumably we will know in advance of the
Senate vote whether there will or won't be
a conviction if half the country has been
waiting for Trump to be impeached for years.
It does make sense that it wouldn't move the
market that much if you believe in how the
the, the market always assimilates known information.
Um, then it was already part of the stock
market level, the desire and expectation and
ultimately the realization that Trump would
be impeached would have already been priced
in.
Now the bigger issues are of course the stock
market is not the economy.
A lot of people who just work for a living
their day to day is not guided by the stock
market.
It is guided by what is cost of living.
Uh, what are wages doing?
What is going on economically in their state.
The stock market may indeed be in a bubble
that's heading towards popping at some point.
That's been said for a very long time.
We have serious trade policy issues in the
country that are now hurting farmers and manufacturers
in many States.
Those don't look like they're going to be
resolved anytime soon.
But the major conclusion here remains Trump's
presence in the white house is not the heart
of the stock market's success the way that
Donald Trump has claimed for awhile now, Trump's
predictions aren't particularly good.
Trump's sense of self importance in the economy
is drastically overblown beyond his ability
to actually hamper it via destructive trade
policy and ruining international alliances.
Maybe these are not surprising conclusions,
but it's good to see evidence of them publicly
every once in a while because it was not only
Donald Trump, but even some of the people
around him saying it would be very, very bad
for stocks if Donald Trump were to be impeached.
Well, he's been impeached and stocks are okay,
and of course you're not going to hear Donald
Trump talk about that other than on days that
stocks are up.
Continue to take credit on days that stocks
are down claim as he did during the recent
NATO summit in the UK.
Oh yeah.
I don't, I don't really pay attention to the
stock market.
Don't be tricked into believing that Donald
Trump's presence in the white house is crucial
for a stable stock market.
And then of course, I think most of you know
and are not tricked into believing that the
stock market is
the
economy for
the average American worker.